tu nous racontes aussi un monde qui qui
est que tu as abandonné il ya plus de
vingt ans mais fake mais qui est quand
même un monde où il ya de la passe et
pas seulement de l'acte abandonné mais
c'est ce qui était graviter autour qui
est l'alcool la drogue la défonce soyez
vraiment ça ben oui mais c'était de ça
semblait normal il y avait une maison de
disques leur logo il y avait une ride de
cocaïne en travers bon c'était les
disques barclay dans les années 90
c'était ça leur nouveau logo il y avait
il y avait cette espèce ouais mon
premier voyage de presse j'avais 20 ans
je vais voir bad company à glasgow je
n'ai même pas mis dans le livre parce
que c'est tellement énorme que donc on
nous on est là on est plein de petits
journalistes très jeune on vient voir du
rock on est content pour lui ai dit
voilà on va prendre le bus pour aller au
concert on arrive dans le bus et sur
chaque siège et 20 petits paquets de
cocaïne mais à l'époque en fait le rock
et drogue s'était pas tabou et sari mais
voilà et je pense que ils ont pu viser
les tous les rockeurs ont puisé dans
cette drogue une espèce d'énergie
fantasme pas n'importe quelle drogue
parce que vous dites c'était comme si
j'étais là quand vous dites dans votre
livre vous dites la coke grandir
supercarburant pour l'homme moderne bah
oui c'est un peu à ça que ça semble au
début parce qu'au début on en prend
wahou bomber le torse on devient
superman et il n'y a plus de limites on
en croit que tout est formidable et il
est facile puis on a le pied au début c
était des grandes fêtes formidable on
est plein de copains de la télé la
cetera pu puis c'est encore après la
fête est finie on se retrouve tout seul
avec un dealer chez soi et on se dit
mais je suis devenu un toxicologue chez
ces malades et avanade c'est pas bon
quoi c'est là moi c'est là où ça ça a
commencé je me suis dit mais qu'est ce
qui se passe mais en fait l'industrie
avançait tout avancé avec josiane vers
blizzard de cocaïne qui s'était abattu
sur le rock alors justement vous dit que
il ya une forme d'hypocrisie quand même
y avait une forme d'hypocrisie ckoi
l'hypocrisie du milieu du disque c'est
qu'on veut pas voir où on voit et on dit
que c'est que c'est pas dangereux à
l'hypocrisie parce qu'il y avait plein
de chanteurs notamment vous parler de
deux chanteurs évidemment américain
lemmy de motörhead on sait david bowie
plein plein d'artistes heureux
bien sûr mais en france vous dites des
chanteurs et puis parce qu'on imagine
oui notamment
des chanteurs à chemise hawaïenne un peu
plus
stupéfiant pour moi de quand je suis
arrivé de me dire ça alors lui aussi il
m'est fait c'était incroyable j'étais
stupéfait célèbre française dans les
années 70 80 il s'en prenait tous j'en
prenais beaucoup en poney beaucoup à
vous avez toujours des cas particuliers
je cite formidable le chanteur
d'indochine nicola sirkis que moi j'ai
été en studio tout de suite on les a
invités aux enfants du rock on était en
studio avec eux tisane été
refusé de boire un verre d'alcool ou une
coupe de champagne alors qu'il veut il
était numéro 1 avec l'aventurier et il a
toujours tenu cette ligne si j'ose dire
jusqu'à nous le nom mais jusqu'à nos
jours est vraiment remarquable parce que
je crois que c'est un cas unique
après vous en avez d'autres sites
inconnus johnny hallyday 1 10la là il a
ni un monde en 98 j'ai un problème de
cocaïne il parle à daniel rondeau la
france s'arrête encore à quoi lui aussi
c'était ça paraissait fou et ça
paraissait fou qu'il l'équipe qu'il le
fasse écrire dans le halal alors johnny
et or johnny coutu a un problème il
convoquait le monde
voilà un problème effectivement mais
alors il ya un moment
il ya un espèce de mythe une légende qui
dit que l'alcool et la drogue ça stimule
les artistes à stimuler leur créativité
ça les rend meilleurs est ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec ça ou bien
fantastique au début il ya une toute
petite période de 1 an ou effectivement
c'est la créativité c'est la joie on a
des nouvelles idées on va faire des
trucs personne n'a jamais fait honda
l'énergie de s'empiler à 5 dans une
camionnette pour aller jouer à perpignan
pour défendre l'album et après on va
bordeaux en vient à lille on repart tout
ça ça avance on tient par par un miracle
et puis un moment bon bah c'est fou du
tout la créativité à pied puis un autre
problème c'est que les gens deviennent
très méchants ils sont en mains tout le
temps la dissolution d'oasis à paris
c'est le manque il était une pouvait
plus sous x la dissolution croyais que
c'étaient les frères gallagher frères
gallagher et qui en fait ne se pouvait
plus se voir et en fait c'était lié à la
drogue était lié à sa vie normalement
alors plus les réactions des maisons
j'ai jamais pouvoir l'arrêter jouer il
dit moi je pourrais liberté pendant
réservé à la question les réactions des
maisons de disques elles sont très
cotonneuse parce que les maisons disent
le dit ce mec il a vendu 10 millions
d'albums on va pas l'engueuler s'il a
envie de se détruire nous on vend des
disques c'est tout bêtement amy
winehouse quand
destruction en ralenti pendant deux ans
tout le monde savait ce qui allait se
passer il y avait on ne pouvait rien
faire elle avait vendu 20 millions
d'albums avec 40 millions d'euros en
banque qu'est-ce que vous qu'est ce que
son père chauffeur de taxi allé lui dire
elle avérée selon tous les critères
l'élégant la laisse ça justement vont
vous à vous on vous a pas laissé vous
détruire et deux femmes qui sont très
importantes dans votre les vies et dans
votre livre est la première c'est
virginie despentes vous dit en gros que
c'est grâce à elle que vous avez arrêté
tout ah là là elle me regarde
et des pentes une immense écrivain
auteur fait partie et voilà et on vous
essayez d'être ensemble
on avait cette envie et on s'est dit on
va se désintoxiquer on va tout arrêter
parce que ce qu'il faut savoir un couple
qui essaye de se désintoxiquer c'est
raté tout de suite ça peut pas y en a
toujours un qui rentrent le soir en
disant chéri j'ai rencontré mme asha on
va faire une petit à petit accroc au
contrat et boum ça repart pour eux donc
nous s'est désintoxiquée et de l'alcool
et de la drogue parce qu'on n'avait moi
j'avais un gros gros problème d'alcool
parce qu'à force de prendre des
substances alors on arrondit avec le
jack daniel's pardon je devrais pas cité
les noms mais on a rendu un message
alors je vais vous dire quelque chose
philippe vraiment je trouve absolument
merveilleux que vous racontiez tout ça
parce que vous le dites avec vraiment
beaucoup de franchise beaucoup beaucoup
de sincérité en même temps dans le livre
vous expliquez aussi à quel point c'est
une descente aux enfers parce qu'il ya
la période festive que vous avez doté
d'un qui est d'un an et quelques et
après ce n'est que du manque que de
l'enfer voilà le de la destruction de la
descente que de l'art descend de la
méchanceté gratuite va voilà et donc
arrêtez ça a été fabuleux formidable et
merci virginie dont on sait bien aidé
l'un l'autre on a tenu et là on est
alors cette barre c'est très beau à la
fois ce couple qui renaît ensemble et en
même temps il ya aussi un autre
personnage féminin dans votre livre est
extrêmement important c'est votre fille
ah bah oui puis
et puis ma fille bien sûr vous raconter
le jour où vous où justement vous
découvrez que votre fille prend de la
cocaïne voilà moi je me disais je me
vois la très mé ment je me disais bon
moi j'en ai marre et donc ça s'est réglé
dans la famille donc mes enfants
n'auront pas besoin d'en prendre et un
jour je rentre de tourner la nouvelle
star et elle avait laissé plein de
journaux sur la poubelle qu'elle ne
voulait plus lire et donc moi papivore
je me précipite pour voir ce qu'elle
jetait s'il n'avait pas un journal que
j'avais pas lu et tombe la fameuse pie
rouge jaune blanche a enfin la fameuse
pas et pardon mais on connaît pas la
fameuse panne alors il la fameuse les
toxicos adorait aller chez mcdo prendre
à bail joueurs de blancardy ne les ai
pas eus mcdo quid des tsé et quand j'ai
vu ça là j'ai vu j'ai eu l'impression
que je me se faisait renverser par un
bus quoi c'était donc j'ai poussé un
hurlement j'étais tout seul dans
l'appartement a déculpabilisé ben non
vous êtes m'a dit c'est moi qui
peut-être et donner les vélos je me suis
dis donc là la race humaine va jamais
rien n'approuveront des condamnés à tous
recommencé et je me suis rendu compte
qu'en fait c'était un chemin personnel
que chacun devait mener quoi tout ce
qu'on était tout seul en fait et puis
moi alors je me suis dit je vais le
l'engueuler puis rossi mais toi personne
tant que lui puis si tu rates tu vas
faire là tu n'avais rien dit vous
n'allez pas vous avez aimé plus en toile
a quant à elle quand elle est revenue ce
soir là j'ai je me suis dit cette petite
ville entourée de double d'affection
j'ai été un papa qui faisait qu'il
pourrait par monts et par vaux il a
élevé on va aller au concert ensemble
qu'est ce que tu veux aller voir
ailleurs fifty sainz qui passe à bercy
on y va j'étais avec quelle joie et bien
qu'il se disait pourquoi il est tout le
temps là
les avis est-ce que vous avez découvert
mois n'avait jamais parlé ensemble on
n'a jamais parlé jusqu'à il ya quelques
jours qu'elle quelques semaines avec
l'état les anges rade terminer le livre
il m'a dit tu sais j'ai tout arrêté
l'alcool et la drogue j'ai fait comme
toi j'ai tout arrêté et je me suis dis
donc ça y'est merci bravo et l'ami comme
tout le monde est comme dit un moment
lou reed édiles c'est un circuit de 10
ans faucon théorie d'un célèbre chanteur
mourir dans l'oreillette
il y avait fondé le velvet underground
toutes les chansons les chansons sur la
drogue et lui disait c'est un circuit et
un cycle disant et si tu prends de
l'héroïne tu as beaucoup de chance de
mourir avant et puis il ya ceux qui nous
écoutent ce soir c'est vraiment vraiment
instructif l'après d'écouté philippe là
dessus